hello everyone Alana here today we are
playing both spoken I'm gonna play
probably the first 30 minutes or so here
on YouTube and then I will stream more
of it on Twitch I thought so
let's go default difficulty setting
uh I'm gonna go quality focused for now
see if maybe I want to change that later
um Square Enix did provide me with a
code or something very thankful for
obviously I've had a lot of opinions on
this game family
excited to see how I feel about it
beliefs your home
doesn't matter who you are there's just
some things you have to protect
but what do you do when the world fights
back
guess I know now
wish I could go back in time and tell
myself let me turn on uh subtitles
for everybody watching at home it's
probably in display settings or sound
settings
sound settings
accessibility settings
menu settings subtitles here we go
on
that should be good
but I was not ready to hear it
okay sort of a strange opening but
there's a courthouse in New York my
head's coming in case of people the
state of New York versus Alfred home
defendant charge would attempt to grand
larceny
how'd he plead not guilty your honor
I see
officer please remove it it looks good
I think
now before we begin
perhaps you should reacquaint yourself
with your many previous encounters with
the law
okay and not how I expected this to
start I'm all right with this
uh
uh diploma
I haven't seen this in a while okay
that's just a graduation certificate for
high school
all right document in the middle
t lawsony Grand Larceny burglary in the
third degree
all right not my best angle
nothing like a trip down memory lane oh
she's an orphan
why are you here free grand larceny is
that who you really are
no it's just I needed the cash for
never mind that was a bit weird sooner
or later you're going to have to start
taking accountability for your actions
this is a very strangely paced opening
scene for sure
are you familiar with the persistent
felony of Fender law also known as the
three strikes law wait you can't do that
I never hurt anyone just yourself you
have two previous felony thefts and with
this new one your grand total will be
three
this could put you away for a very very
long time you have so much potential
I can do so much more with my life I'm a
smart girl with a bright future I was
going to say you have so much anger and
resentment in you I'm not sure you'll
ever amount to anything at all
truth hurts I like the judge but
in the holiday spirit
I'm going to give you an early present
try not to piss it away
I'm going to release you under the
condition you serve 120 hours of
community service
next time you end up in front of sick
beanie though it's real nice
good
you're free to go also if I look
extremely tired it's because I am sorry
about that
pray
one more thing
I guess they know each other happy
almost birthday
it's not too late to start using your
gifts to help others
I don't like her performance in the
scene I'll be honest
um
I don't know
all right so obviously we're starting in
New York rather than in this fantasy
world that we've mostly seen
that was close
judge might have just saved my ass oh
that I like the performance there that
was good
hey excuse me your phone oh my gosh
thank you so much no worries happens to
all of us you saved my life seriously
happy holidays
um happy holidays
it was odd
I should get back to Homer a girl needs
her dinner it's a very cute looking cat
um all right
I guess they're showing this like the
just juxtaposition of where
New York starts out uh tracking
objectives in the journal and your
objective has just been added you can
check your current objectives in general
their judge may have had a point but
it's not like I can just change who I am
and if I get caught one more time my
life is over which is why I gotta get
the hell out of town
okay we're trying to get out of town
straight home
the lights are nice
excuse me I said I was tired
gotta get inside
for some reason right now to me this
feels like Yakuza
like the way she's running around the
sort of empty streets I just need like a
bunch of mobs to come try and fight me
hello goodbye
oh [__]
right thought we wouldn't find you
hey uh
uh Lisa
Lisa really I thought she was Lisa
that's Chrissy huh
you don't really look like Elisa
oh where is it oh I don't have it all
right there were complications not like
I wanted to get caught stealing the car
but here we are
we don't like complications
you are running out of chances
yeah I've been hearing that one a lot
today
foreign damn this is like going pretty
hard
it's not that easy it's been impounded
feel about this car anyway it's none of
your damn business
our boss Mr Gigan is very unhappy
so unless you get it back one of us is
gonna be in a lot of pain do I get to
pick
this seems okay
I do think she's overly quippy but then
I also feel like like
Nathan Drake is kind of like that like I
think we're sort of at a point where but
maybe just over it
like Nathan Drake would make a dumb quip
here right
again all right
gig I just tell him that was strange I
need some more time but but for now
here's some collateral
she can like [__] well even in the real
world
school I guess
okay there is something odd about like
immediately just being in with a
character who's committed crimes
um
and not really being on a side with them
though
I'm so sorry
I gotta find a way out of here I mean
you just like
threw a brick at somebody
um
I think that dude will be all right oh
the camera right now is I can't control
the camera
it's very weird
maybe it's safe to go through
okay
they can't see me they really they can't
see me they didn't see me just do that
okay good it should have
oh
don't they just give up already
hopefully I'll lose them when I get out
on the street
we'll see what I want to say for
reference like people criticize the the
protagonists or or auxiliary characters
talking too much a lot lately
um and I agree I think characters
talking too much is really annoying I
don't like it at all
um dissolving the puzzles before you can
I don't like it but
um
a lot of the time it's a result of play
testing
well virtually all of the time which
would probably be the case here as well
it's usually that um play testers have
said wasn't sure what to do in this
section didn't know where to go in this
section
and the best way to make sure you're
trying to make a quality game is to try
and get full mocks during play testing
it's really kind of your only option
waiting for me
um
so a lot of that
as before I freeze dialogue banter
talking to yourself stuff like I gotta
go down the alley better get inside
before I freeze
um is a response to
people who play tested it
giving it a nine instead of a 10 on a
certain section because they weren't
exactly sure where to go
which is unfortunate because play
testers sometimes don't uh reflect
majority of players
game systems the archive that archive
records the details of any written
materials you find people you meet at a
host of other useful things and access
it from the main menu okay
any useful information you've acquired
oh for a free Holland resident of Hell's
Kitchen is just about to turn 21 having
been abandoned as a baby near the
entrance of the Holland Tunnel she spent
the years that followed moving from one
house to home to the next foster home
sorry upon graduating from high school
she set out to make a life of herself in
the city despite her repeated run-ins
with the law since then she's decided to
make a clean break someone is she
am I a bad the judge
we saw Ortega as the gang leader
Christy Robinson gang member
okay
World tutorials
I don't really feel like I need any of
this right now to be honest
New York City yeah we've been there it's
Christmas it's true
pretty magical 511 huh she tall
until she's found right cool got it
look for Homeland looking for the cat
okay
did you just move here are you just
moving out what's going on
that is not the cat
curiouser and curious sir cried Alice
wish I could find that rabbit hole and
Tumble away to Wonderland
nice foreshadowing yep
and you will
[Music]
yeah okay
the Holland Tunnel side of my folks
great disappearing act
who leaves a newborn baby on the street
well at least it wasn't the Queen's
Midtown Tunnel that would have been
enough
okay
she doesn't like this
that's all I have it's a good looking
box
like that that cat food box
shop where Homer's at
well you could try and pour the food for
the cat that might help
you give that a shot
my favorite kicks
I could stare at you guys all day
somebody who likes and has a lot of
shoes
um that are sneakers I have never
fondled them
but go off I guess
this is a big apartment are you paying
for this in Manhattan
was the Grand lost any money
[Music]
finally I can start over
took long enough though
foreign
that's very funny to me I just think no
one would ever do that
oh
so what are we up to uh on your escape
plan that you have on the wall
take care of Gigan one last time
I think
that's what Homer shows up nice
it's a very cute cat
I'm sorry I'm late I'm
just me
oh well thank you but my birthday isn't
for another few days
I'll tell you what I just forgot
I've been so busy recently
oh well you know
important things to do
going for it slaying dragons
I'll let you in on a secret but I'm a
pretty big deal
real big deal
everybody needs me
we are getting out of the city Homer
away from the [__] the garbage the
cops I
just again you've got it pretty good
here if this is what you can afford in
Manhattan I promise we'll go somewhere I
mean I know there's nothing in there but
the size
go come on now you doing all right
he says no more cops no more fights
[Music]
one more sleep
well you didn't take care of Gigan it
was on the no escapeless plan that you
wrote on the wall as everybody does
I can't wait to be any other place with
this
damn okay
[Music]
so this game's getting criticized for
writing a dialogue a lot so far it's
fine
um this opening is certainly a bummer
with not a not a great indication of
like what the gameplay is going to be
um especially considering how
largely different it is from this
opening sequence
um
it feels like more like a life is
strange right now
the Homer girl come on we gotta go
wait I thought I didn't gotta fight
Homer come on baby
where's the cat where the cat at
Homer holy [__] I don't know what cats
would actually do in a fire they'd
probably run away right
no no no no
get the bag
window it is
okay
what started this fire
[__] oh okay awesomeness got it
well that's a shame and finally The
Blaze that engulfed in the abandoned
building in the Hell's Kitchen district
oh she lived in an abandoned building
got it she was not paying rent for that
which I should have put together when
she didn't walk through the door to be
fair but I am tired
foreign
what happened to you
you look like hell
are you allergic
what
to cats
are you allergic to cats
oh I love cats but
are you in trouble good
she likes wet food the flaky kind
not pate
she needs a warm place to sleep flaky
wet food every once in a while
and she needs a bath but good luck with
that pray what's going on her name is
Homer
promise me you'll look after her
promise
that's a lot to put on someone
what are you doing free
the right thing
I need some time to sort some stuff out
but I'll come back for her it just
might take a while right wait if you're
in trouble I can help you free
happy holidays
why why didn't we ask for help
directly I feel like we should have done
that all right
Homer said
I'm currently quiet at odds with the
protagonist
okay
how'd you get up there
I guess you can do the parkour
full circle
happy birthday to me
she born on Christmas thanks Mom
no I'm better than that
no I'm gonna fix things
get Homer back finally get out of
I wonder
like this city doesn't look great
um
note that that bothers me but um I
wonder why the game was so graphically
demanding on
on PC I think it was the ram
the specs were pretty nuts they're not
necessarily graphics cards but
what
wonder what that is
anyway once again don't have control of
the camera it's weird
feels like I should but
I guess they wanted to restrict what we
can do in the city clearly not a ton of
detail here which is kind of a bummer
when it's the opening of the game
I would have thought this way but
oh I just walk off
my bad
it's beautiful
it is nice
nope not getting in that way must be
another way
yeah the camera's um
a bit of a butt in this game no one in
here
seriously
who would just leave this
I mean wow
is that I'm pretty quick I feel like
it's been 20 minutes maybe not yeah not
that fast
foreign
yeah we'll save
what
the
vehicle
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait stop
stop [__] [__] [__] [__] oh no
good that's what this stuff usually is
it's just a person
sent to a magical world from The Real
World it happens
this certainly looks a lot better than
New York did
you get out of the room you mean walk
out the door
what's happened to me
that was strange that is a serious draft
a lot of cutscenes
whoa
[Music]
it's a shame The World Isn't
a little more colorful or something
who's there and technically well no you
would call us anyway I swear to God
[__] Show Yourself show myself I'm
sharing I'm showing you I can't get more
showed show myself where are you right
here at the end of your arm
the thing that you so fruitlessly tried
to remove
oh hello yes so perhaps you're smarter
than you look yeah good uh good actor no
this Jarvis like yes
you the one talking to me right now or
this
cuff
it's a bit reductive isn't it a cuff
Gauntlet maybe van brace oh fan price
yeah no it's definitely better no no no
a little bit much
but what you're doing is completely
futile
how is this happening I don't mind this
as much as I expected to thus far she's
fine she really annoyed me in the demo
um
but right now it all makes sense
[Music]
doesn't matter
still here
whoever is doing this stop this is one
sick joke I am out of here
can't run away from me I can't currently
move attached to you
why don't we settle down it's and talk
about ourselves
talk about our interests in life perhaps
I am not hearing this this is all a bad
dream
be careful not to trip on anything it
annoyed me the first time see things I
don't like how she goes every time she
goes to water a ladder
I'm so sorry
how the hell do you know my name we are
bonded bonded what do you mean bonded
why is this happening
this is no on Bond on bond now
as you can see you're stuck with me and
I with you and only you can hear
stop stop talking this is
Fray slow down you need to listen to me
the pacing of this conversation is
really odd is
oh okay see it
hide
is that a [__] Dragon don't let
it see you
thank you
I like a dragon
I guess we'll be fighting one of those
at some point
is it gone yes and we should leave this
place as well
there I don't think so I'm sure the
creature is far away by now besides what
you won't last long without anything to
eat
fine
and how exactly do you plan on getting
out
I believe
climbing that wall might be our best
option
I'm also definitely like curious about
the context of the world so far
this isn't about opening
you'll occasionally be able to stop and
chat with cup about recent developments
when this happens simply pick a topic to
start the conversation hey cuff
um what are you exactly
so if we are bonding correction bonded
whatever
each other then What's your deal by deal
who are you I am what you see
lovely and I suppose you'll tell me more
if I answer your riddles three
I don't follow
never mind
she's a little too Brash for sure like
Nathan Drake wouldn't have said
something like that we talk about like
the Banta The Cheeky bantuan being
attacked by a bandit or something sure
but that probably not
[Music]
um
so have you always been this this this
this this chatty bling as I recall no
what do you recall
I traveled here
Matthew was not my home
I like you I'm an outsider
when I arrived there was a lot of
turmoil between the tortoise the who was
the taunters they were four very
powerful women who ruled athia each with
a special ability
like what magic or something it's my
magic you mean the ability to turn me
into an inanimate object then yes
powerful sources who saw seriousness who
once ruled over atheists for around each
embodied a different virtue which in
turn shaped how they choose to rule
they were much loved by the people of
Athea who enjoyed lives of planning
under their guidance but according to
Cuff all was not necessarily as
harmonious as it might have seemed on
the surface
cool
how'd you wind up in that stall
why were you rusting at that old shop
anyway
it was weird delivery myself
all I do know is that before I visited
Earth I was here in Africa
[Music]
how dare you yeah she's a bit a bit much
in this conversation I think
we'll find out what brought us here as
you are
and I think like a lot of the disconnect
that a lot of people are feeling with
the dialogue in this game and this again
this is not that bad so far I'm fine
with it
um
is that
we don't relate to her like I am not as
frustrated at this cuff as she is
uh and that's causing a major disconnect
like I'd be curious I'd be kind of nice
I'd be asking for help having someone be
like so you are the reason I'm here
is just a bit much
smartphone it's for texting calling
games videos taking selfies and which by
the way I'm not gonna explain to you so
don't bother asking yeah yeah
it also has GPS which would usually tell
me exactly where I am it sucks that I
can't walk while this is happening
somewhere between purgatory and Hell
sure did
the phone Freya uses stains watches but
it's pretty much it doesn't get cell
coverage can only use the camera cool
never mind
where are we dropping boys can I move
can I move I'd like to move no okay
Waypoint
it's like a fable
whoa
who was that
oh one of
them settlement up ahead okay cool let's
go you know about how oh my God please
let me move
like either have it be a cutscene
oh my God it's okay this is Athea Janu
Janu I thought you said Athea big
picture Junoon small picture Junoon is
I get it like New York City versus New
York State exactly
I think
I have no idea what new arc is
no not in Newark New York
a lot of cut scenes let us stop it and
talking so far which is interesting for
a game that really seems to hinge itself
on fluid movement look at you
you'll be shy seriously I wouldn't let's
just keep moving why are you so freaked
out by this fella
what did you think it was oh he's dope
actually
you told me that now [__] oh I like him
well don't just stand there
are you gonna tell me how
what the don't stop panicking now
cause protective powers
you won't need to do anything to make
him block you and you can't find him
did I just do that well definitely with
my assistance I did not just do that we
did
I just move [__] with my mind perhaps
our connection has somehow awoken some
abilities I just moved [__] with my mind
I just keep hearing III I just moved I'm
fine with the writing here freaking mind
oh okay
do magic talk to sentient
Define
okay yeah that's the one that was in the
trailer good to know there was a line
that's not great I was fine with the
writing before that
take out that gnarly Beast
the combat at this point is very
reductive
um
uh games experience with the virtual
um oh I'm stuck again dude oh this is
annoying me so much more than I ever
would have guessed
let me move
um
yeah for a game that I get I think ends
up pretty having a pretty extensive
combat system
healing drafts and health free can drink
healing drops in order to restore for
help wonder what can have caused such a
mutation yeah like what happened here
like what even happened here though
might as well talk with this this is
crazy
it does feel weird that I can't choose
to block I'll say that
it says the auto blocks but I really
want to do it myself it feels very
very odd
foreign
[Music]
what the hell what is this weird feeling
this seems to be some sort of malignant
miasma in the air okay turning back now
it doesn't seem to be affecting you
though does it besides I doubt there'd
be much benefit in retracing your steps
so this miasma what exactly is it it's
quite mysterious isn't it I suspect it
might be what's causing not a fan in the
way they're giving me the law dumps
right now I think is the big thing so
how come it doesn't affect me
could it be thanks to your commendable
choice of traveling companion Birds
no not that definitely not that
nothing but ruins let me move looks like
no please let me move I wonder how long
is it a loading thing
maybe it's a tutorial thing
or something there
[Music]
support magic provides a wide variety of
effects and can help turn the tide to
battle in your favor
costs your currently selected spell with
L2
open a menu from which you can select
another with L1
it takes such a long time to recharge
that spell
so long
if you can get rid of those cooldowns
so much for clean air and bright Skies
is that on the other side try to escape
to someplace better and where do I wind
up some place 10 times worse oh poor you
just feels very Bleak like
almost like an MMO type landscape you
know
it's it's not a very exciting World
which is unfortunate because I feel like
when you jump into like a foreign world
oh it's gonna be here aside from
thinking that the monster designs are
pretty interesting
um it's It's gotta be riveting out the
gate I would think
I am locked on
gotta be careful
search magic using attack and support
spells gradually charges your surge
Magic
uh have a job today
that's the top one here
right now this feels like I'm using like
a bad pistol
killer blows if you manage to break your
enemies composure they'll open
themselves up to a brutally damaging
attack that will exploit Cub's abilities
to capabilities sorry to deal with
devastating damage if you're close
enough you can simply press triangles
when we should
ah good night
[Music]
oh my God let me move
it's annoying me so much mana and magic
you level up an answer Mana which can be
used to teach very new spells in order
to do so you need magic section of the
main menu magic you can spend Mana here
to learn new spells Mana is gained by
leveling up and can also occasions be
found in another term
[Music]
cool
not bad
thanks Professor I told you to call me
van brace
sure cuff sure
it's weird because it feels like she's
flirting with it
it's [__] a bit odd that's all
it might need to run this time no
kidding
yeah let me just let me do it
okay this is awesome I am catching some
serious air
she definitely also just a little bit
cheesy that's that's I think the thing
um certain enemy attacks can inflict
status ailments such as poisoning or
stamina draining these can make a battle
extremely difficult to try to avoid the
attacks and question if you can everyone
else fails
just gonna keep running
and I'm not even getting tired
uh-huh
that was close
where the hell are we now the big city I
suppose
hello
anyone home
say something if you can hear me
well let's keep looking
you should probably keep an eye out for
so much of rest too
let's see what's over there
setting a destination yeah like a map
got it okay yeah
gives an overview of the surrounding
area and your location at the center
okay let's go there
that tracks yeah
is there not a single person left
it very much seems that way perhaps this
oldness with the air drove them to
escape to safer class
Critical Hits attack an enemy without
them spotting you or get a strike in
from the side or behind and inflict an
extra powerful critical attack
I hope so at least that would mean
they're still alive yeah tell me
yeah so far this is not fun but I'm sure
we'll get there
there was like I liked the in the demo
um the sword thing I had because this is
really just like mash all too
but like you know like I said like
before it's like a bad pistol but it
doesn't feel any better than that
because
um you're not aiming it just it kind of
just aims for you
well this place is fun
I imagine it was once happy smiling
faces on every corner no I could picture
it now
damn everything just looks broken
not exactly the most poetic of
descriptions but yes I suppose it does
I I like the interior of the city parts
is there nowhere that's not like broken
by this [__] I suppose there might be
somewhere yeah
it's just a bit strange she does talk
kind of like a teenager would I guess it
just
not one that I enjoy the company of is
the problem uh
corruption came and from the first date
emerge it was clear that nothing would
ever be the same again for its once
Carefree people those it touched with us
forever those lucky enough to escape it
were forced to abandon their homes to
flee to KIPP pole the only place where
safety could be found or so they
believed
okay
cool
and the game just froze
so I think we're gonna leave it there
um still feel like this is very much
very early very intro very opening so
it's not really enough for me to like
get much of a grasp of the game
um I was okay with the opening she's
only started to annoy me dialogue wise a
little bit further in now
um which I was expecting to be a lot
worse based on the demo and the trailers
but I was okay with it here
um but I think it's so much story
content which I guess was the part that
probably was also bothering me at the
same time was the prevalence of
cutscenes and pauses uh something that
I've never been a huge fan of when you
can deliver something in gameplay I
prefer it to be delivered in gameplay
I've just always felt that way
um but yeah I think I'll try and stream
a little bit more of the game on Twitch
um just for anyone who's curious who
doesn't know if they want to buy it
themselves I know a lot of people are
unsure again very big thank you to
Square Enix for providing me with the
code I appreciate it and I will see
y'all later bye